in the opening scene a young Scout Boy
is standing at a busy intersection in
Bangkok amidst the hustle and bustle of
the traffic he notices an elderly woman
struggling to carry her bags across the
street seeing her difficulty the boy
rushes to her Aid trying to assist her
in crossing the road safely however in
the confusion of the moment he drops his
mobile phone on the street and leaves it
behind while helping the woman to Safety
First just as he turns to retrieve his
phone the traffic lights change and
display leading bus hits him leading to
his untimely death chivalry is not dead
chivalry kills the next scene introduces
the protagonist fuchit poignathong why
do I feel like this guy's name is going
to get this video demonetized who is
facing numerous challenges in his life
he is a Salesman at Yamaha company where
he is constantly belittled by his boss
and colleagues alike in addition his
girlfriend seems to have broken up with
him in order to be a pop star leaving
him emotionally shattered despite his
best efforts to make ends meet futchit
is struggling with his finances living
alone in a small apartment and burdened
with mounting debts that he cannot seem
to overcome the constant pressures of
his life are taking a toll on him and he
is growing increasingly desperate to
find a way out of his predicament on a
certain day budget heads out to his
school to sell his products to a
potential client however he is
crestfallen to discover that his
colleague has already made the sale
there the very next day budget leaves
his home to go to work but to his dismay
he finds that his car has been
repossessed by the credit editor due to
his failure to pay off his debts fudge
its day at work takes a turn for the
worse when he is called to his boss's
office and told to resign due to his
poor sales performance returning to his
desk he is further disheartened to find
a pile of overdue bills from credit
companies adding to his already mounting
financial troubles feeling depressed
facet goes to the staircase to gather
his thoughts and have a cigarette but
his frustration only intensifies when he
realizes he has run out of them to make
matters worse his mother calls and asks
him to send money to pay for his younger
sister's schooling despite his
precarious financial situation fuchit
agrees to send the money just then his
phone rings again and he answers only to
hear a stranger on the other end
offering him a chance to win 10 000 Baht
initially futget suspects that it's a
prank call from his colleague or friends
but the caller proceeds to reveal
personal details about him such as his
full name age and employment status
which leave him wondering I mean sounds
like it's probably his friends the
caller then tells fujit that he simply
needs to swat a fly that is buzzing
around him right now if he completes the
task he will win a cash prize worth ten
thousand Baht fudge it is skeptical but
after some convincing from the anonymous
caller he decides to give it a try he
rolls a newspaper and easily swats the
fly the next second surprisingly he
receives a message confirming that 10
000 bot has been transferred to his bank
account as futget gasps in excitement
the caller offers him the chance to win
50 000 Baht if he eats the Dead Fly
uncertain and hesitant fuchit returns to
his desk with the dead fly in his hand
contemplating whether to go through with
it or not however after a while of
deliberation he pops it into his mouth
one of his co-workers Tong notices this
but she's so bewildered that she doesn't
speak a word after some time budget
receives yet another phone call and the
caller informs him that he has the
chance to win an enormous sum of money
100 million bot if he completes a total
of 11 more tasks despite feeling uneasy
about the mysterious caller in the
dubious nature of the game futget is
desperate for cash so he agrees to the
terms and conditions the caller warns
him that if he quits or if anyone
discovers that he's playing the game
he'll have to forfeit all his winnings
immediately for the third task fletchit
is assigned to go to a kindergarten and
make at least three children cry
although hesitant at first he recalls
his own traumatic childhood experiences
with his father crushing his toys so he
steals toys from the children and makes
them cry the fourth task involves
stealing money from a bagger a
reprehensible act that futch it
reluctantly carries out things take a
hard turn with the fifth task Fletcher
is ordered to visit a high-end Chinese
restaurant where he is presented with a
plate containing feces and instructed to
eat it although he feels disgusted and
protests the caller insists that he
complete the task or risk forfeiting his
prize flashbacks of being bullied into
eating dog poo as a child further add to
his distress But ultimately futch it
forces himself to finish the plate even
this time long catches him in the ACT
she starts assuming that he has gone
mental either that or he's broke you
know as the Twisted game progresses the
challenge is become increasingly
degrading unlawful and deadly prior to
embarking on his sixth task budget is
instructed to hand his phone over to a
deranged individual at a bus stop
through him fuchit learns that his next
challenge is to fight a group of teenage
Hooligans on a moving public bus in
order to acquire another cell phone this
will not be as cool as Shang Chi
initially futched attempts to negotiate
with the delinquents for the phone but
when they start to bully him he ends up
getting into a physical altercation with
them during the brawl futched in one of
the Hooligans fall out of the bus
sustaining injuries however the fight is
not over yet as the teenage Thug pulls
out a knife and advances towards him
just as he is about to attack fuchit
grabs a large piece of meat and Strikes
the assailant's head rendering him
unconscious and fulfilling his sixth
task the next challenge is even more
harrowing fuchit is instructed to break
into a house and retrieve the corpse of
a deceased individual the problem is
that it lies at the bottom of a well not
only that fuchit also has to notify the
deceased family members and the total
time for the entire task is just 10
minutes it is a momentous and scary
challenge but since budget has come this
far there is no looking back as he
descends into the well he notices a
swarm of cockroaches on his arm that
startles him and causes him to fall into
the water after taking some time to
gather his composure fuchit ties the
rotting corpse to himself and begins to
climb out of the well despite the
limited time frame he manages to get out
and call the family members right before
the deadline expires shortly thereafter
has given another task one that involves
physically assaulting his
ex-girlfriend's current boyfriend sure
says fudget surprisingly fletchit is
quick to accept this one oh
I was joking and without hesitation he
picks up a nearby chair and unleashes a
brutal beating on the man until he is
knocked unconscious however futch it is
soon overcome with guilt for his violent
actions so he quickly rushes the injured
man to the hospital as [__] it continues
to progress through the increasingly
challenging and morally questionable
tasks the police begin to take notice of
his criminal Behavior led by Officer
surachai a team of Cops start to track
futch it down suspecting that his crime
spree is part of a larger and more
Sinister scheme meanwhile Tong becomes
increasingly concerned about fuchit's
odd behavior piecing together Clues she
overheard at the police station she uses
her computer expertise to hack into a
website called 13. there she finally
comes across the live stream of fuchit's
horror show every movie makes everywhere
he goes is being recorded however Tong
has no idea that she is also being
closely monitored and that she has
unwittingly become a part of the very
game she is investigating in the next
scene fuchit who is now a wanted
criminal finds himself in the hospital
there he sees news that the police are
after him his phone suddenly rings and
the same mysterious caller warns him to
avoid the police as his capture would
mean the end of the game and the prize
money would be lost despite the
potential danger fuschett continues with
his next task the eighth one which
requires him to help a patient escape
from room number 803 of the hospital
hiding from the authorities futch it
reaches the specified room surprisingly
the patient he is supposed to help is
the same elderly woman from the first
scene with some quick thinking futch it
disguises himself as a ward boy and
manages to load the old woman into a
wheelchair and escape the hospital right
before surajai and his team arrive in
the meantime a higher ranking police
official orders Suraj Shai to call off
the pursuit of the wanted criminal after
leaving the hospital fletchit brings the
elderly woman to her modest Hut by the
side of the main road he then helps her
dry her clothes by tying a silicone wire
however unbeknownst to him the other end
of the wire is fastened across the main
road is invisible in the darkness soon
after a group of teenagers on motorbikes
whiz by completely unaware of the wire
resulting in a horrific accident that
causes one of the Riders to lose their
life this tragedy leaves such a
devastated and he lashes out at the
mysterious color on the phone who has
been guiding him through these heinous
tasks as he is coming to terms with the
grave consequences of his actions Tong
arrives on the scene and gets shocked to
witness the aftermath of the accident
she implores fudget to turn himself into
the police assuring him that they would
understand the circumstances behind his
actions Tong also reveals that she knows
about the game he has been playing just
as they are speaking the phone rings and
the caller informs futget that the game
is over as someone else has discovered
it however he gives futget one final
chance and assigns him another task to
kill Tong's dog it turns out the little
pup has been kidnapped and brought to
the elderly woman's house already when
Tong sees him she is taken aback she
begs Fletcher to spare her dog however
the ladder has become so obsessed with
the game he brings out a sharp weapon
and mercilessly slays the innocent dog
fuchit then warns tongue to stay away
from him before speeding away in his car
fudget has truly embraced his name after
the incident Tong who is determined to
uncover The Mastermind behind all this
decides to head to the police station to
report her suspicions however she has no
solid evidence to prove her claims
because the website which she hacked
previously is now completely blank
disheartened she leaves the station
feeling helpless and lost as she walks
out she stumbles Upon A group of
villagers who are arguing amongst
themselves Tong approaches them to check
on the matter and learns that someone is
shockingly sliced their cow with a
samurai sword this sense shivers down
her spine as she realizes that it's none
other than futch it Tong follows the
trail of blood he has left and reaches a
strange room with the number 13 on it
however as she is about to enter it a
man captures her from behind Tong is
then taken to the place where the
reality game is is being run from as she
enters the premises she is confronted by
The Mastermind behind the game a young
boy named key he is revealed to be the
same Scout boy that we saw at the start
of the movie surprisingly he never died
the old woman somehow saved his life
Tong tries to reason with him and asks
him to put an end to the game claiming
that it has already taken the lives of
many innocent people however key reveals
that he is powerless to do so because he
is just a component of it and the
underground reality game involves
players and viewers that perhaps number
in the thousands elsewhere as fuchit
reaches the final destination of the
game he is taken aback by the Revelation
that the game is a social experiment and
all his actions were being monitored and
recorded the entire time he is then
confronted with a daunting task of
stabbing his own abusive Father John
Adams who is strapped to a wheelchair
and appears to be unconscious this final
task promises the prize money of 100
million Baht and fetch it is torn
between the temptation of winning the
prize and his conscience he starts
having flashbacks of the time his dad
did good things for him like chasing
away the bullies and bringing him new
toys ultimately butcher decides to give
up the game as he remembers his mother's
wish that he should never become a bad
person like his father but just as he is
about to leave Adams wakes up and stabs
his son to death with this key from the
control room announces that Adams is the
winner of 100 million bot it turns out
he was also playing his own game and the
final task was to kill his son while
fletchit hesitated to complete the task
Adams didn't Tong is devastated to
witness the cruel turn of events and she
screams at Key however the young
Mastermind remains unperturbed he
instead reveals that thousands of people
just like futchit and Adams are playing
the game currently moreover millions of
viewers are watching and betting on the
games worldwide and that is where all
the money comes from saying this he
causes security and escorts Tong away
from there in the final scene we see her
waking up on a bus bench disoriented and
confused Tong is found by surajai who is
still investigating the deaths related
to the game
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching